hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
the fundamentals of freeze drying
advice from the experts on how to get
started
presented by megan zimmerman the product
manager at lab congo corporation
and jenny sprung senior application
specialist at la pronco
corporation i'm michelle ashton of
labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labbers
and sponsored by labconco for more
information
on our sponsor please visit labconco.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab down at the top
right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
this offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process
to obtain your credits i'd like to now
introduce our presenters
megan zimmerman and jenny sprung for a
complete biography
on our speakers please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
megan and jenny you may now begin your
presentations
thanks michelle and thanks to everyone
for joining us today
going to start by discussing the general
overview of the freeze drying basics and
requirements
followed by how to select the right
freeze dryer for your applications
then i'm going to pass things off to
jenny and she'll talk about developing a
protocol
freeze-drying challenging samples and
troubleshooting
we're going to start by discussing some
common terms you hear when talking about
free shrink
freeze drying is the process of removing
moisture from the frozen product using a
vacuum
another common term is lyophilization
which is just another word for
freeze-drying
the term is derived from the greek word
solvent-loving because these samples are
easily rehydrated
this allows for easy re-suspension of
samples making it a great process for
sample preparation
sublimation is also a word you'll hear
when talking about freeze drying
this is the process and freeze drying in
which solvents pass directly from the
solid phase to the gas phase which is
what gives free stride samples such
great preservation properties
it's important to note the rate at which
sublimation occurs is dependent on
temperature and pressure
the image displayed here is a phase
diagram showing the process of
evaporation and sublimation
while evaporation takes a sample from a
liquid to a gas
sublimation requires a solid sample that
bypasses the liquid phase and passes
directly to the vapor phase
when freeze drying it's important to
cool the material below its triple point
shown in the diagram the triple point is
the highest temperature at which the
solid and liquid phases of the material
can coexist
being below this point ensures that
sublimation rather than evaporation
occurs
there are four important criteria that
need to be met in order to freeze your
eyes successfully
the first requirement of previous drying
is that you must have a pre-frozen
sample before you start your run
as the vacuum pulls down on the freeze
dryer you may see the sample begin to
melt until the appropriate vacuum level
is met so it's important to have a pump
that's in good working order
by nature water molecules from your
sample will want to move to the
coldest spot in the system that's why
the second requirement of freeze drying
is that you have a collector that is 15
to 20 degrees colder than the sample
freezing point
in order to trap those vapors coming off
the sample
the third requirement for freeze drying
is having a deep vacuum with a minimum
requirement of .002 millibar
this is necessary because the vacuum
pump establishes negative pressure
forcing free water molecules that have
left the sample by sublimation
the last requirement for freeze drying
is having energy in the form of heat
while it might seem counter-intuitive
the optimization process
is essentially a heat transfer process
it
it's important to note though that if
you add too much heat to certain samples
you could cause those samples to melt
and undergo evaporation
one example of the heat transfer process
is with
flask free strength as the flask hangs
from the manifold
ambient heat from the room temperature
is driving the heat transfer process
because you can't control heat input
with this method
it's considered uncontrolled heat with
the use of a tray dryer you can control
heat input into the samples this is
important for samples in the
pharmaceutical industry
or with the production of samples that
require long-term storage
to help develop a freeze drying protocol
for methods using controlled heat
you can send your samples off to
companies where they will watch the
freeze drying process
under a microscope they can then tell
you the sample stripple point and what
amount of heat input would be good
throughout the run
in general most labs will just
guesstimate that heat input
fine tuning their process to develop an
optimized globalization run
next let's talk through how to select
the freeze dryer that's right for your
application
one of the first things you'll want to
think about is who is using that unit
if the freeze dryer will be used by
multiple groups you'll need to know all
of the solvents that could be utilized
you also need to consider who will be in
charge of preventative maintenance of
the freeze dryer and vacuum pump to keep
everything in an optimal working
condition
it's critical that you choose the right
materials when selecting a freeze dryer
many solvents used in samples can attack
plastic and rubber components which
cause vacuums
to leak over time the use of acids can
also damage materials like stainless
steel and acrylic
once you determine the types of solvents
that will be used with your freeze dryer
you can apply the following criteria to
help you select the right unit
freeze dryers typically come in
collector temperatures of minus 50 minus
84 and minus 105 degrees celsius
keep in mind that the collector
temperature you select should be 15 to
20 degrees colder than the freezing
point of your solvent
in order to effectively trap those
vapors on the collector coil
you also need to determine the collector
size of the freeze dryer
freeze dryers are described by their ice
holding capacity
so if you're looking at a four and a
half liter freeze dryer that means it
can hold four and a half liters of ice
before needing to be defrosted
however this doesn't mean that you can
put four and a half liters of sample on
the freeze dryer at one time
instead you would put about half of that
volume on there to accommodate all of
the vapors that come off of your samples
when
the run starts the next thing to
determine is the type of vacuum pump
that you need
in addition to having the correct vacuum
pump specifications
the solvents being used will determine
whether you operate with an oil rotary
vein pump
a hybrid chemical resistant pump or the
use of a dry scroll pump
there are a variety of ways you can
freeze dry your samples so you also need
to consider the method that's best for
your application in order to select the
correct accessories
besides selecting the correct type of
freeze dryer you also need to select the
right manufacturer
one consideration is how the coil is
designed to collect the vapors coming
from your sample
with our internal coil design we're able
to provide the coldest possible
temperatures
and are superior in capturing the
solvents coming off the samples compared
to an external coil design
that is on the outside of the collector
chamber
a vacuum control valve is another
important feature to have in your freeze
dryer
by being able to set the vacuum level
you're able to speed up the run runtime
when using
certain solvents
other considerations include the types
of controls the freeze dryer has
whether gmp requirements need to be met
and if you need the freeze dryer to have
pre
pre-freezing capabilities
when it comes to controlling your freeze
dryer the software you have is critical
one consideration is how you plan to
access data
with the layer works operating system
you're able to download your data to a
usb flash drive
or use an ethernet connection to send
your data log
straight to your computer through a
one-way connection
remote notification is also available
you have the ability to configure the
types of alerts that can be sent to your
phone via email
this is a great feature to have with
freeze-drying since most runs take 24
hours or longer to complete
you won't be left wondering how your
samples are processing when you leave
the lab for the night
endpoint detection is another feature to
consider if your flask
is pre-shrinking it can be difficult to
tell when these samples are truly done
myopolizing
and it leads people to ending their runs
too soon or running for hours longer
than is necessary
the end zone endpoint detection can help
you avoid both scenarios by alerting you
when your samples have achieved
the level of dryness you set at the
start of the run
now i'm going to pass things over to
jenny so she can discuss developing a
protocol
great thanks megan megan discussed how
to choose a lyapolyzer
now we're going to talk about developing
the protocol there are three steps in
the freeze dry process
pre-freezing is your most important step
if the samples aren't frozen
solid melt back will occur knowing your
sample's freezing point is extremely
important primary drying will remove 92
to 93
of the moisture from the sample and will
be the longest step of the process
again you want to make sure your samples
don't melt during this time
finally secondary drying will remove the
residual moisture from your samples
and takes about one third to one half
the time as primary drying
there are different ways to pre-freeze
stub freezing
limits the surface area and is not the
preferred method to pre-freeze samples
in
flasks subfreezing can be put stress
on a flask especially during dynamic
temperature
changes this method is best for serum
vials on a tray dryer
okay slam freezing is a preferred method
of freeze drying
over stub freezing and flasks slam
freezing provides a large
surface area and decreases the freeze
dry run time
shell freezing is the optimal method for
freeze drying in flasks as it maximizes
the surface area to volume ratio
by spreading the sample throughout the
entire vessel
this gives you optimal surface area
and it optimizes the heat input to the
sample
providing a large contact area between
the sample
and the flask
by controlling the rate of pre-freezing
you can change the size of your ice
crystal
pre-freezing results in larger crystals
which freeze dry
faster it's best to know your samples
and how they respond to the freeze dry
process now we'll move on to primary
drying
this step will be the longest and remove
the majority of the moisture from the
sample
during this step adding heat is
favorable to the process
on shelf you have to control how much
heat is added
the shelf temperature should be set to
just below the sample's freezing point
to prevent melting
on ports the heat will come in the form
of temperature from your room
if your freeze dryer is sitting near a
window or other heat source
melting can occur by controlling your
vacuum pressure you can also speed up
the lyo process
the typical recommendation is 0.2
millibars
for most samples
the ability to run primary drying at
higher product temperatures
greatly reduces drying time by creating
a larger pressure differential
between the vapor pressure over ice in
the product
and the pressure at the condenser each
one degree
increment increase in product
temperature can decrease primary drying
by 13 percent
secondary drying removes the final seven
to eight percent of moisture
that primary drying did not remove it
adds
additional heat to drive the freeze dry
process
secondary drying works best using
controlled heat on product shelf
but can be done in flasks by adding
additional insulation
to warm the flask the temperature can be
as high as 50 degrees c
during secondary drying because the free
ice
is now removed maintaining the same
vacuum pressure
is advised as lower vacuum levels will
not speed up the process
samples can be stoppered under vacuum or
nitrogen for long-term storage
after the freeze dry process is complete
now we'll discuss the best conditions
for the room that the freeze dryer will
be placed in
room temperature should be around 22
degrees c and the room should not be too
small
remember the freeze dryer and the pump
will create heat
on their own keep the unit away from
windows and heat vents
both can cause melting during the
process by warming the sample above the
eutectic point
if the freezer is located far away from
the freeze dryer make sure you insulate
the samples during the walk or drive to
the freeze dryer
to prevent melting before the samples
are placed on the freeze dryer
look for liquid surrounding samples to
determine if meltback occurred
some samples may require additives if
they are not freeze drying correctly
or giving the outcome desired these
include
bulking agents thermal stabilizers lyo
protectants
and ph adjusters
if your lab requires gmp for your freeze
dryer
there are a couple things to keep in
mind gmp regulations neither approve nor
prohibit specific equipment for use in
manufacturing
firms are afforded the flexibility to
select equipment that best satisfies
their particular needs and they are free
to modify standard equipment designs to
best
suit their process manufacturers can
provide
the materials of construction a qa test
report
for the specific freeze dryer that was
ordered
manuals videos literature dimensions
etc to help you run your unit
an iqoq is typically offered by the
manufacturer to be done by the customer
however pq must be done by an outside
consulting firm
not all samples are a good fit for a
lyophilizer
these next few slides will talk about
the samples and how to overcome their
challenges
some samples don't give a nice powder at
the end of the run
tert-butyl is one of the results in a
gummy end product
alcohols are difficult to freeze dry
because of the low eutectic temperature
and lack of temperature differential
between the sample and the collector
temperature
they must be diluted to 10 percent
or less and use a minus 105
freeze dryer for successful freeze
drying
dmso is known to attack rubber and
plastic components which are a big part
of any freeze dryer
because of this these parts may need to
be replaced over time to prevent any
vacuum
leaks sugars and salts lower the
eutectic temperature which require a
cascade type
collector they can also bypass the
collector and get into the pump as
particles
an inline hepa filter will protect the
pump from these particles
soil samples are typically aqueous based
however
the particles can migrate into the
vacuum pump and again get into the oil
and cause damage to the pump
an inline hepa filter is also
recommended when doing soil
samples if your samples are fruit and
vegetables
the best way is to homogenize them or if
at the very least
poke holes in the skin to allow a way
for moisture to leave the sample
this is true if you're running animal
samples as well
freeze drying is an art and things may
go wrong during the process
most of the issues can be overcome by
taking a few steps
if your samples are not staying frozen
make sure you're using the correct
collector for your sample
remember a temperature differential of
15 to 20 degrees
is required small samples tend to melt
faster than larger samples
insulating them will help if there are
alcohols in the samples
again make sure you dilute them and make
sure you're using a minus 105 degree
freeze dryer vacuum pressure should not
be too high
if you can't get a good vacuum it may be
time for an oil change
as the samples dry they become powdery
and could get pulled
out under a deep vacuum using filter
paper or parafilm will help prevent this
and remember colder is not always better
when it comes to freeze drying
if the samples are taking too long to
dry check the shelf temperature
and make sure it's close to the sample's
freezing point and not lower
surface area will help speed up the
process if the sample is too
thick it's going to take a long time for
the moisture in the bottom of the sample
to move through the already dried upper
portion
also make sure you have enough space
between the flask and the rubber top
this is especially important if you're
putting test tubes inside of a flask
if there's a not enough space between
the top of the test tube and the rubber
top
it will prevent vapor flow
poor vacuum can sometimes be fixed with
an oil change if one has not been done
for a while
check your oil after each run to make
sure it's not too cloudy or dirty
you can also check the valves and
gaskets for cracks or tears that might
cause a leak
if samples are not sealing correctly
make sure they are evenly spaced over
the shelf
prior to stoppering those samples
many things can cause the final product
to look different between
runs change in room temperature
temperature or purity of the solvents
and the percent of the active ingredient
in the samples can cause these
differences
this is very common in the freeze dry
process
ph shifts are common with buffers
we're ready to take any questions that
you may have
thank you megan and jen for your
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
all right let's go ahead and get started
okay first question
is at what temperature must the sample
be
cooled before lyophilization
well it depends on what's
sorry megan go ahead um
that's a really great question but you
know as jenny was starting to say
it just depends on what the sample is
made up of
um so you know we say that
choosing a collector for a freeze dryer
you need to have the sample
temperature differential between 15 and
20 degrees colder than the sample's
freezing point
and you can kind of use the same logic
for
when figuring out what what temperature
you need to freeze your samples at so
if you're doing an aqueous based sample
you know anything below freezing is
typically
fine you know a lot of people have minus
40 freeze dryers that doesn't mean
that you can't use a minus 80 or colder
it just isn't necessary um so don't feel
like you have to go
colder in order to completely freeze
your sample
great thank you all right next question
what is the suggested
room temperature to run lab concho
freeze dryer
yeah so that's a really great question
as well because sometimes
you know we get people that call us and
say they're having trouble with their
freeze dryer you know their samples
melting
all of that kind of stuff and a lot of
times it has to do with the heat load
inside of the room so i will say
that when we test our pre-strayers um at
labconco before we send them out to
customers
we do all of our quality control testing
in a temperature-controlled room at 72
degrees
um and so really anywhere between 68 and
72 is an ideal temperature
to run your freeze dryer
thank you and what is the name of the
accessory that indicates when flask
freeze drying is complete
that would be our end zone endpoint
detection system
and if you have any additional questions
about that feel free to reach out to us
but
the you know like we kind of covered in
the presentation it's really just
um the use of vacuum sensors measuring
the vacuum level inside of the sample
compared to a reference
port on the manifold
thank you and does it matter how i
pre-freeze my samples
pre-freezing is actually the most
important step of the process
you want to get as much surface area as
you possibly can so
shell freezing in flasks is going to be
the highest recommendation if you cannot
shell freeze then slant freezing is
going to be the the next next
thing
great thank you now would you recommend
lyophilizing
products in the 96 well plates and if so
how would you be able to control the
exposure once the door is opened
well so 96v plates can be tricky to
freeze dry because there's a couple
things
first of all the samples are typically
very very small
so if they do melt during the run they
could potentially pop
out also if they're very powdery once
you do vent
the vacuum you could lose uh some of the
powdered sample the end sample
so if you can somehow cover the the
micro plates with either parafilm or a
filter paper
and then poke holes in it that's going
to really help you with
with the whole process and prevent loss
of sample
great thank you now this question says
that you said
0.2 glycerol vacuum is required
does this mean that the minimum 0.2
vacuum required to start freeze drying
process
i hope that makes sense
well with our freeze dryers you can
choose what vacuum setpoint
you want so it really is going to be
dependent
on what your sample is in general we do
recommend the 0.2 millibar
it will help speed up your
lyophilization process
so i think that's what what they were
asking if not i can follow up with an
email just to make sure that we got that
one covered
perfect thank you all right next
question
how can i seal under vacuum without
buying a stoppering tray dryer
we all yeah so oh go ahead jenny
okay what i was going to say is we offer
two different options so if you don't
want to invest in a stop brain tray
dryer or a triad unit
you can either look at a clear manually
stoppered
chamber what that allows you to do is a
clear chamber with two
shelves inside of it you put your vials
on the shelf
and then you manually crank
the stoppering mechanism to raise
those shelves up and stopper or we also
have what's called a mini stop brain
chamber which can be hooked onto
ports of the freeze dryer
i believe you can run up to eight vials
at a time
and you would just stop for under vacuum
but this would be great if you just had
a port type freeze dryer but needed to
stop for
just a few
now what are the suggested containers
glass beakers plastic bags like zip
locks
etc to freeze dry samples
sorry michelle can you repeat that one
more time
sure let me pull it back up
okay what are the suggested containers
to freeze
dry samples for example glass beakers
plastic
bags tubes etc
okay yeah so it really just depends on
what your end goal is
you know if you're trying to prepare
something for long-term storage
or you're working with things like
pharmaceutical research a lot of people
want to stop or under vacuum and so
they'll use
either glass vials or ampule pods that
they can flame feel under a vacuum
if this is just meant as a sample prep
step for you in a series of testing
then you could use something like flask
freeze drying or
trays but anything that's just going to
allow
that that vacuum to flow freely so
something like a plastic bag unless it's
sitting open
you may not get that vapor transfer that
you would
if you were using a material that had
like a permeable membrane
so just something to keep in mind when
you're
selecting sample containers
that's great we have so many wonderful
questions coming in from the audience
we'll just take a couple more and this
one says what is the best freeze dryer
to use for someone starting up a
small agro processing production
well the best one really is dependent on
the solvents that you're going to be
using
so before you buy a freeze dryer what we
always recommend
is knowing who's going to be using it
what
solvents or is it just aqueous that will
be run
on the unit and then you also need to
know
how many liters of moisture you want to
remove
at a time so before you you decide on
what you want make sure you have those
questions
answered labconco actually has a
questionnaire that can walk you through
each and every
item that we need to know about and so
we can send that to you prior to making
a recommendation
thank you okay and our last question
today is if the samples contain
a little of organic acid is it okay for
lyophilization
um yeah so with organic acids
the only thing that you really want to
make sure is that you've got the right
type of freeze dryer
so we do offer um ptfe coating
for our collector chambers and coils but
you also need to be mindful of the
drying accessory that you use as well so
with organic acids you want to stay away
from acrylic because it will etch
and crack over time and and you know lid
materials you
you likely want to go more with a a
glass lid so
when you're selecting your freeze dry
equipment just reach out to us and we
can help walk you through the types of
materials that you need to look for to
make sure that you have a free strayer
that will last
thank you and i want to thank the
audience for their great questions
any of these questions that we did not
have time for today
will be addressed by our speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration
thank you again megan and jenny do you
have any final comments for our audience
before we go today
well we really appreciate everybody
joining us today
and you know like michelle said we'll be
reaching out so we look forward to
speaking with you guys
i do just want to say though that we do
have for those who are looking to get
started on their work quickly
reach out to us we have a limited
quantity
of select free dryers available for
immediate shipping so
we are ready to help you get started and
i think that's it for me jenny did you
have anything else
nope that's all i have but we will be
reaching out to everyone shortly
thank you again megan and jenny for your
time today and your research
i'd like to thank lavrov and our sponsor
lab conco for underwriting today's
educational webcast
until next time goodbye
you